on conflict driven close learning set
solving
and how it can be used for optimization
problems selects without further Ado
please okay thank you very much
so this talk consist of two parts in the
first part I talk about core cdcl Supply
which will be mostly a review of the
foundations of City cell and then I'll
talk about solar complex open with
optimization problems with sat so the
first part is mostly about the past and
the second part
I believe should be an opportunity for
the future based on my own industrial
experience which I'll share with you
so let's get started
let's get started from the very
beginning although everybody knows that
but still
so sat is the problem of determining
whether a Boolean formula in CNF is
satisfiable
and it's the original complete problem
there's a famous book writing to learn
from the early 70s
is
frequency site is the most important
outstanding question in computer science
so it's all down both around the
question if checking a solution is it
whether it's also easy to solve the
problem
and it's still a knowledge of mystery
right so it's one of the most intriguing
open questions in computer science
but
however such solvers are highly stable
tools so how come there is this gap
between theory and practice
so we don't know for sure but what we do
know is that um the fundamentals of
of the modern fact solvers the
fundamental algorithm there is backup
search and it was developed in the early
60s it's called BPL or dll
so let me show you how to get from some
basic enumeration to cplnn and then we
will get to CDC
so uh they so we have the same formula
right we have two closes here literals
and so the easiest way to solve it would
be to to come up with this enumeration
of all the possible solutions so we just
build this these three and then you have
the vortex which corresponds to variable
and then
to the left and to the right and then
you have um so you enumerate all the
solutions and then if there's a right
Square it means that the formula is
unsatisfiable and and the green square
which means it's satisfiable
so this is kind of the basic approach to
solve this problem right the status
approach but then of course you can also
stop when you close comes unsatisfiable
right in this case the first nose turns
unsatisfiable so you can stop here so
this is one Improvement made by the
authors of dpln
and then uh like
the most um
interesting idea there was to carry out
backtrack search and then stop when the
first model is found because you need
only one model so you just pick a
variable you assign it to some value and
then you pick another variable send it
some value and then you stop because the
closer it was not satisfiable and you
flip it
and you find the models
and then yet another Improvement which
was to introduce already in detail in
the original in these two original
papers
is has something to do with unit closes
where a uni close is a close in which
one variable one literal is unassigned
and the rest are fortified
and then one can observe then in all the
courses might be satisfied and then in
the unit close rule is
um
and it says that you must assign the
unassigned literal you must satisfy it
so the Amazon theater must be implied in
the close
and um so it was observed that it pays
off it really pays off to apply the
universal fixed points which is known as
temp Corporation so in this case we will
just pick your variable send it to value
and then D would be implied right in the
first laws it's very close
a little pixie and then you would just
sort of find find the model okay so this
is the basically algorithm
however the parent could handle really
small formulas with under 2 000 closes
while Motors and solvers can hope with
huge industrial instances in instances
of hundreds of millions of groups so
again how come
and so the tournament point was the
introduction of cdcl conflict dream
close learning course
and that was infected doors in modern
times
so the idea
is to learn from conflicts right from
those experts to drive and from that
research that's the basic idea of
conflicting solving
and let me go over the intuitive
principles for modern citizen substance
so the first one is learning and pulling
so whenever there is a conflict you want
to learn some strong things with some
some Clauses and improve the search
then there is the locality principle so
you want to focus your search on the
relevant data
so if you cannot find such data then you
will apparently fail you won't be able
to solve the formula but the sad solvers
are really good at it so they can find
some local context and learn some strong
closure from from that context and then
go and find another local conflict okay
this is only kind of um
not not precise understanding right just
heuristic understanding but I think that
if you cannot if they cannot be local if
you cannot find a context to learn from
then you will just fail
then there is the third principle of
bell engineered data structures
um which was nice to extremely fast
Boolean constraint proposition DCP and
these days there is also there are also
some orthogonal techniques in the CD
cell like in processing and very
recently local search integration
so these are the principles behind
modern physical substance
and in the first part of this talk I'll
um
give you an index dive in the core of
the core I call the corner light soup
and boiling constraint propagation only
so I won't talk about that
other algorithms
um
now the seminal works the two seminal
Works foreign
by the Pistol Group
and it was also aborted by the cover
board
so I'll go over the algorithms of chaff
and graph and compare them
but first I would like to talk about
Boolean concept propagation
so the Boolean propagation vcp is a
crucial algorithm because it consumes
the vast majority of the runtime of
modern fat solvers so what it does
it first it identify and propagates in
unit losses this is essential for
performance so you can kind of skip the
source cards
um because this is not really necessary
because when you if you if you even if
you skip it and you once you decide well
the detail you were identified at the
closest
is the unit essential
but this is really good for performance
to identify genitals and propagating
them and then it's essential for
correctness to identify and import any
conflicts you cannot afford yourself to
skip conflicts right because then you
don't have authorities
so how is it carried out
okay so um every literal holds a watch
list
with all the clothes where L is watched
and then when the leader was falsified
the silver goes over resets all the
codes in in the watch list of not l
and so it really pays off to keep that
watches short
so let's go over efficient rate of
factors for BCP
so grasp washed all the electrons right
but then the crucial observation that it
is sufficient to watch two letters was
made by Handel Zhang in satoshat solver
so here there are it's it's sufficient
to watch two
so liters which are either unassigned or
satisfied
to ensure to guarantee that the close is
not units nor conflict so you you just
hold these two pointers but in Sato
um there was an order between uh these
two watched letters there was a head and
a tail and then all the letters to the
left of the head were
um were falsified you had to ensure
they're falsified and the same goes for
the litter to the right of the tail and
which also required the solver to visit
losses by backtracking
and then
um that was that limitation was removed
by the authors of chaff and they
observed that it is sufficient to watch
the first two letters in every course
and then you do not need to visit closer
during backtracking
and you also need to make sure though
that the decision literal of a falsified
watch if there is a falsified watch is
uh not lower than the decision level of
falsified non-roaches in order to
guarantee that when once you backtrack
the for the watch literal becomes
unassigned before any non-worship and
then we are fine
all right so the last thing I wanted to
mention here
is that it was found that caching one
literal of the clothes inside the watch
list
really pays off because then if that
letters is satisfied you don't need to
go to the close itself in the closed
database and so you save cache misses
and the related observation is that uh
you don't really need to store buy
macros at all
um in the closed database so for example
Kisa does not store binary codes
okay so the this slide summarizes the
official data structure for DCP
and now we go back to confession
analytics so I I'm now going over
confessionalize the algorithm of shaft
and that of grasp and then we'll talk
about four options
all right so
um considering the formula on the left
and let us recall how Chuck works so
first it would pick a decision variable
and say date and decision level one
and it will try to propagate the dpcp
but here it cannot be propagated so it
will pick
um the next decision literal B
and c and d
and then at this point they actually
have liters implied by previous lessons
literals so it would imply F in C5
because F tons unit
and it would imply G at C3
and then there will be a perfect
because
um
then C2 will become falsified
so here is what Chuck does when there is
a conflict
it launch a falsified so-called
assorting clause
so the first letter in the close is
always the literal of the last decision
level then the largest level data then
there is a literal of decision level
beta Lord and Delta and then the rest of
the literals must be assigned must be
falsified on decision labels which are
not higher than bet so we have decision
the highest decision level then the
second highest decision level and then
the rest of them and chapter
closes I'll remind you about the first
30 very soon after that a champ box next
to level beta
which renders this closed unit and then
you can flip C1 with C with this Clause
being its parent close and run Bishop so
that's a charts algorithm in a nutshell
let's continue this example so in order
to lower close
um you one can construct an implication
graph
so another way to look at it would be
through resolution derivation but here I
present this way
so in the implica the implication graph
essentially shows the dependencies
between the implications between the
liters so for example G
is implied at close C3 right
because C was assigned to an F was
Central
Etc and then you can draw this first uip
cut
so on the right hand side there is the
conflict and on the left hand side there
is the reason including the so-called
rightmost unique implication points
which is f so this is essentially a
literal of the last decision level which
is sufficient to out of the liters of
the last decision level it is sufficient
to imply the conflict together with
other returns from previous decision
levels so there it stops
and there is an Associated close um
so which comprises not F because f is in
the on the left side of the cut not C
and not B if you learn this close it
will prevent the the conflict from
reappearing so chuck would learn that
close it would backtrack non-cologically
to decision level three so it would skip
the decision level of D because it has
no part in the conflict
and then
um after that it would flip F in that
newly Run course
and there will be something some further
implications in this particular case
the conflict so they put again generate
this implication graph
along the first epic close
which is in this case f or not a
then it would backtrack non-core
logically to decision level of a because
B and C do not contribute to the complex
and continue in this manner okay so this
is Jeff this is the well-known classical
algorithm
let us now go back to grasp and and
recall how functionalities look looked
and grasped
Okay so
the algorithm was a little bit more
complex so there was a preliminary step
of backtracking to the conflict level
Delta that was caused non-crological
tracking in grass
okay we will talk in a minute why grass
needed this preliminary backtracking
then it will still learn a a falsified a
certain first way to close this this
step is similar to chaff it remained in
chaff
also learned a clause per every other
UAP
of the last level
but then it was backtrack to level Delta
-1 rather than to battle which is
currently called conversion in the
modern literature right
so grass would do again in in modern
terminology
and then it would again flip and
implicit one so let me show you how it
works on this example so again we have
the same example and the same
decisions here A B C D and E the same
implications and we get to the conflict
so here first sharp would sorry grass
would learn the floors to repeat close
similar to chaff then it would also
learn the the second uip close another
clause
okay so it corresponds so here the
unique implementation point is e the
decision literal of the last decision
level
okay so this is also a valid Clause
corresponding to the cut
so it would around several courses
if there was a third date it would also
learn a closed seven
then it would better to decision level
four so it would carry out essentially
again model terminals chronological
networking
and would flip
would flip F in grasp f is called a
special kind of a flip decision variable
at level five but it actually proceeds
as if it were a
electron implied at level three
so okay so it is essentially implied at
level three because C6
right is um
it consists of literals
B and C and the highest literal of them
is C which belongs to level three
so again despite the fact that we are at
level four
that this liter is implied at level
three at a lower level
and then it would imply G at level three
and
this is the implication graph so now
here we have this preliminary step the
computer course at level three
but and we need to backtrack to the
conflict level before doing computer
knowledge so grasp would actually better
at this point
would remove level four because it's not
related to the content and then of what
again Lower it would learn the first
articles the secondary clause
backer chronological name
okay and continue in this map
so this is the algorithm of grasp yes
so the summary here is that on the first
conflict
the summary here on the first conflict
instead of just jumping immediately it
tries to imply the last variable that
was assigned by decision
to lead to a conflict it checks to see
if the other assignment is now an
implication of the conflict and if it is
then it backs track
important on the first one back is it
would always
like a short here well I mean you call
it chronological but what it did is okay
yeah we have a terminology uh confusion
over here that's what but what it does
is instead of just saying either a
conflict if I make this assignment and
then backtracking narcologically it
tries the other assignment by
implication it says since this
assignment led to a conflict the I think
what to Apollo called it is the uh um
failure driven assertion it says the
other value is also not a decision it's
a it's an implication yes and if that is
unsaid if that is a conflict it backs
tracks
yeah I think yeah but I mean again I try
to formulate it in modern terminology
but this is the same algorithm yeah I
talked to joao essentially in a very
long email email thread and he agreed to
say that this is essentially the same
after all right
the interesting thing that modern Souls
actually put back to Grassfield which I
will show next
um so let me now present or summarize an
up-to-date context analysis of algorithm
which covers grass and chaff but also
modern Souls
there is this preliminary backtracking
step of backtracking to conflict level
if required okay so it's done by grass
but not by not by chance
this was in charge of the current
decision level is all
um
the quality is always the conflict level
s
then the soldiers learn in a certain
clause which is the first step because
of most grasp and chaff
an option is some other clauses for
example the other tools which correspond
to the other devices
and then they backtrack to a decision
level inside this interval between beta
which is the level to which shark would
benefit
and the Delta minus one so grass always
better to Delta minus one which
corresponds to chronological but I think
in today's terminology
and chuck would always better to better
okay now model solvers I'll talk about
it in in the next slide they sometimes
back to Beta sometimes to Delta
management sometimes two levels in
between
okay uh but still this theme covers all
the sources as far as I know all the
modern solvers
and then there is this step of flipping
C1 and Time blanket in the newly
generated course
so this sums up the functional super
algorithm as implemented in modem
service and also in the first series
we now talk a bit about more modern
solvers what they do so um so grasp was
invented in 1996 then there was chaff in
2001 and chaff's algorithm which
generates one first AP clause and then
that's not closer the tracking was the
state of that for a very long time for
17 years
until there was this our work about
Maple CB so we implemented convolution
backtracking in the leading solute at
the time yeah one of the brushes of
maple
and what we did there is we Implement a
backtracking heuristic which chooses
between chronological and non-prol
conducting
okay I'm not going to the details but
just that at every conflict you can
choose whether you do chronological or
no scope exciting and this hymn is
essentially used by almost all the
soldiers except for particle which I'll
mention next
so it's used by metal vessels
cryptominated
and so one can say that modern Souls
went back
so do something in between grasp and
chuff okay so they relax this
requirement of betting and non-cological
and it seems to help especially
unsatisfiable incidents
right and the chronological in this
solvers is essentially very similar to
grasps
but
um it was still a huge challenge to
implement it because
if you remember grasp watch all the
letters right in in the course but in it
it turned out that it's difficult to
combine control backtracking with the
two watch literal scheme which is
essential for official discipline and
this is because of simultaneous
propagation at several decision levels
at once so uh it turned out that BCP
must be adjusted to prevent not only
performance issues but also correctness
issues
and then useful BCP environments are
still violated so I'll show you an
example
yeah before I'll just mention Capital so
cardical uses
um a different location scheme it
backtrack to the decision level
in um in that level between the um
highest decision level and the second
correlation level is the greatest
valuable score it's applied by clavicle
and also by my server into submission
one versus mentioned
okay so now
um yeah and in Practical uh there is an
integration between growth habit
pregnancy and modern basic schemes of
course but it's not discussed
Independence so we also did not discuss
it in our original pattern
let me show you why it is challenging to
integrate
um so you should have this clause
okay so the first two literals are
unassigned and the next leaders are
falsified at levels 22.
and then uh assume that the first
literals are falsified at level one
which can now happen because the
implication when chronological
backtracking is applied implication can
be at any level not only at the latest
level
right
but before proceeding you have to flip
liters here you must make sure that the
first two literals are the highest in
the close so don't do that you have a
correctness problem and essentially all
the solar that implementation bullets
right but it was not document although
it's essential for correctness
now let me show some invariants which
are still violated even with the
adjustments
so the first environment I call it
lowest implication
so no assigned literal can be implied at
a lower level so essentially this
situation cannot happen you see there is
a close here with the two liters
falsified at level 10. and then a little
satisfied level 20. now that that
teacher could have been implied in this
close right at level 10. but in practice
and it would be better it would have
been better but in practice all the
model solvers except for intersection
which I'm going to mention
and actually allow for this situation to
happen
and then you you could essentially
compress your decisions and compress
your reputations if you allowed to imply
this cathedral in this close
and then another variant which is
violated is I call it lowest conflict
so in chat for example at every conflict
disappear returns a close falsified at
the lowest possible level so there are
two potential problems here
one at level 20 and one level 30. so a
server which implements
would always find the lowest conflict
but this is not the case for for
government kids that it could find find
this conflict first and then it would do
complete analysis
eventually it would discover the lower
conflict too but it will get time it
will take time and effort yes it will
carry out Professionals for this close
and then after backtracking and flipping
and doing BCP food actually discovered
this conflict as well
there can be any any number of this one
so these two invariants are violence
now in my new solver which I implemented
like several years ago two years ago
I have a new scheme which actually
ensures most implications Most Wanted
so I'm just going to to tell you a bit a
few words about my solver and then I'm
going to move to the next topic so it's
an open source it is also written from
scratch and there is a paper at such and
also recently I gave a talk
um you know able to talk about that
solver which you can you can now seminar
so there is a video of the talk it's
free and there is a public Repository
and it's tuned towards Implement
incremental applications with
multi-satisfiable quiz
in the paper the applications Anytime
work with mock sets but at Intel we are
using it for optimization problems like
placement scheduling Etc
which brings me to the second part of
the stock so now I'm going to talk about
optimization problems
any other questions about the source
parts please do ask them
uh
when you're finding the the conflict
Clause uh uh a lot of programs like like
many said are able to reduce the size of
their Clause uh substantially uh
you take care of all those reductions as
well you know what I mean that that uh a
lot of times you come up with a clause
of size 20 but you could reduce it to a
sign yeah but the decision levels do not
change though so still so I do that too
but it does not change the decision
levels in the close so the close becomes
becomes minimized but the diffusion
levels are the same and so this
distinction between chronological so it
does not change the basic algorithms
that's what I mean although the Clause
is minimized
it does not remove decision levels from
the course
right
let me then move on
so now I'm going to talk about
optimization how you can solve
optimization for problems with such
so
interesting formulate here the the
opposite problem
s is false all the input we have a
propositional form of F and convective
on the form as in the standard thousand
but then there's also pseudobulin
objective function sign
is
required to return a model to the
formula f which minimizes sign
so let me just remind you that this
suitable function is just emitting from
every full assignment to a real number
so for example here we have a suitable
and function
given in a table and then we have this
Formula F it has three models
right and in order uh to to find the
minimal model we just check in the table
the values for every model right so it's
8 75 20.4 and then on offset sober we
just return M1 because it's the minimum
of it so this is the problem
generic model right I don't tell you
here how the function the suitable
function is provided right so that's the
problem
how can you solve this problem in
profits
it depends on side
if PSI is a linear function
right then what you can do is you can
just use max
which is a rich and well established
field there are many markets out there
and they do linear optimization itself
but what if the
function is not linear what do you do in
that case
so it turns out there is only scarce
research on the topic almost no no races
at all so I'm going to to tell you about
our contribution the so-called call set
algorithm which simulates local search
with sat
and it's sufficient and simple to
implement I mean I found it sufficient
in my industrial practice
and then there so there is also another
work which we did about high level local
search when you use a subsover or a post
that solver as an oracle
so I'm just mention it here but I won't
talk about I won't go into details today
so I'll talk a bit I'll talk about for
certain then I'll try to show you some
considerations about the importance of
optimization and future directions
so um
now I'm going to present to pollution uh
is what it does is minimizing a black
box function given a set formula right
so again you have a Start Formula and
you have a function now the function can
be provided to the algorithm when you
implement it it can be provided as a
dragbox function
right so just a function with the solar
pose
so it does not have to be represented in
any any manner
right it can be anything
okay so how how do you suppose that so
first you create the CNF formula and
then you call reset solver
and as I said to provide it a callback
function you can also call it under
assumptions in incremental flows and
then the solver
will query the function when all the
variables are assigned and it explains
the function to return a number
okay and based on that the server does
optimization
and there's no need to beatbox to beat
blast the function into close you can
just calculate it offline so it can be a
complex anything right complex double
function so in practice in practice the
function depends
on
a substitute of variables normally which
I call the observables
and it is strictly monotone in this
Observer so when an observable is
flipped from one to zero the function is
decreased for example it holds for Max
right
so it's a linear function so if you flip
any B from one to zero then the
coefficients are positive and so the
function goes down
but these are distributions can be
lifted
now the idea behind Polo set is to
simulate local search with the Saturn
so here's the algorithm
first it holds a sub solver over the
formula f just to find the first
approximation
and
for
optimization problem and then there is
an external Loop which runs an internal
Loop until the model m is not improved
anymore so the algorithm tries to
improve m in an anytime fashion
now what does the internal Loop do it
goes over all the breadth absorbers
where absorbable is bad it if it has
never been assigned zero in any model
and it tries to find a model in which it
is assigned zero sometimes to flip the
current embed observable as follows
it provides it as an assumption the
subtle provides node b as an is an as an
assumption so notice here that it cannot
find the same model again because it is
guaranteed by construction that will
flip the value of B
here and then if
um performance satisfiable and we found
the better model we just update him
so that's the essence of the algorithm
so do you reach us to a local minimum
yes
I mean complete algorithm it can be
integrated into public algorithms and
I'm going to talk a bit about it when
you get to the local minimum yes okay so
that's all coming back
well in order for the thing to go to
practice there are several things you
need to ensure
first this is really crucial you need to
apply polarity fixing
what do I mean for artificial view
modify the polarity selections Hymn of
the subscribe so wherever a very a
solver chooses a variable
you assign the shortened value so you
override the political decision
heuristic of the stat solver to simulate
local search so in practice what you do
is is the following thing
you fix the value of The Observers to
zero because you want to go to the local
minimum we want to go to the minimum and
the other rest of the variables you fix
them to the best model so far
and that makes the solver so that makes
the solver the local search around the
latest solution
with some bias towards the minimum or a
minimum
okay this is a crucial step
that it makes the algorithm to simulated
local sorry because you always look for
for a closed solution
um another thing which has to be done is
to use a conflict threshold for every
invocation in practice because otherwise
you might get stuck and you don't want
to because you have many many calls to
make and it's just an incomplete
algorithm and then another thing which
helps is
sorry to boost the variable scores of
The Observers so so that you would start
with those robots but if you just fix
them to zero and can you know if if you
use them as assumptions it would never
finish because it's too strong but if
you just boost the the response it
normally makes the algorithm Works
faster to work faster because it will
start with a solution closer to the
meaning
so that's the algorithm
as I said it's an incomplete algorithm
but it can be integrated into high level
compute algorithms by just by replacing
if you have a high level complete
algorithm just linear search for example
which will go over next
then you can just replace such queries
by poster queries and you are done
and then your computer will still work
and if you go faster in management
oh
I'm going to talk about an application
so this is an industrial applications we
are actually using this algorithm
introduction
and for several authentication this is
kind of the main application
and the application is placed
so the problem is about placing cells
on a grid
okay so for example this is a an example
instance and this is a solution
so we just place these cells here right
so there are no floral constraints here
so they're placed and this is a solution
and this problem is already to complete
because the grid is restricted
that's what makes it the complicated
because if
there was a limited space then it's a
simple problem I could see
then in in practice you also need to
optimize your placement
so there's a so-called Nets
so these cells are are marked with Nets
and the placement okay so the next size
is the perimeter of the boundary box of
um
of the Box bounding all the cells which
belong to that map so for example
okay M so this yellow bound bounding box
or net one this is about the box from
that one because it it goes bounce C1
right and then nc3 and C5 so there are
three cells which are marked with with
net one
and they're bounded
so this is an example and the goal is to
minimize the sum of all the net sizes so
you want to sum of all the net sizes to
be minimum that's the goal in practice
because then
um again in industrial practice if you
place them and and we follow this
optimization requirement then relative
is much easier so you have a good
placement
so that's the idea now in practice there
are also some additional constraints
which are translated to something
I'm not going to talk about them
now how can you solve placement
um so you can translate it to detector
logic and then through with bitrate
allergic to some but essentially
um
so every
cell has of course not division of
course in height
and so we introduced two-bit records
which represent the bottom most
important
of every cell
and then
um to find the solution one has to
ensure that there is no overlap between
each pair of cells and the constraint is
written down here
it's quite simple so this is a
constantial bit method logic but it can
be B plus the translated to such and
also you have to make sure that all the
cells are placed inside the grid
[Music]
and this way you can translate placement
to such of course if you have additional
constants you can just um add them to
the formula
right
now
if you want to uh Your solution to be
optimal in some way then you have an
interest or the so-called optimization
model a bit reference
problem obvious problem
so um so in this case you have the
constraints and then we also need to
minimize the value of the so-called
optimization Target T all right where
the ni expresses the net size for every
net
so you can just you can create this
variable for every net this is a bit
better formula yeah and then you have
this target to minimize and you can
provide it to uh two business
optimization model between
now these two they do either binary
social linear search essentially
and here I am going to show you how you
can solve this linear search because
it's faster in practice than binary
search
so first you assert your formula try the
solution and you and then you just do
linear search while new still solution
you will assert that
the value of the target to the lower
then it's very new and you call such so
just this is just linear search this is
a complete algorithm and then anytime
algorithm which is good and then
essentially outperform binary social
algorithms but it still gets stuck in
practice
is
[Music]
now what you can do is just to run the
same algorithm and replace certain
locations with positive locations
and essentially you are done you have a
new algorithm and then going to show
it's faster
than if you're using start only
and now to implement for searching you
need to provide a callback function in
this case the function would simply
return the value of the target which
under the current model
and the observables would be the bits of
the net sizes
and then the function is monotone B
and that's it
and then you can do it you can pick you
can pick an algorithm a complete
algorithm and replace your sub pool by
Polo suppose you need to Define your
optimization your black box optimization
function and observe it
and then
so I'll show you some results on
Industrial attachments
so let me just go to the results so here
what we have this is a timestamp from 50
seconds to 600 seconds
and we measure quality for every timeout
and the quality is just a normal school
so one is the best result and in this
case 0.6 is the most unit now the red
graph here is binary source with sat
the blue one here is is a linear social
set so you can see that linear search is
better than binary search and there's a
huge gap here and what is important for
for this stock is the green line here
this is linear Source disposal so you
can see that there is a huge difference
and here we have a virtual best and the
rest of the figures we correspond to
this
the Fuller paper which I mentioned which
does the local search business over as
an oracle so that improves the solution
further but still you see there is a
huge gap here between
our sources
it works well in practice
and then we also integrated Polo set
into a Microsoft solver TT over W group
was the winner in Max evaluation four
years ago and again we just replace that
invocation by posted in the patients but
um a crucial step in the content was to
use an Adaptive strategy to stop through
such when it gets too slow that would
make made it work for Microsoft inside
the market solo because in Market you
really need to be quick
and because it's kind of linear search a
linear optimization function and it's
easier
than more complex nonlinear functions
and then you can see again these are the
results so here
this is the Baseline solver
again we have here timeouts from uh one
minute to half an hour and here is the
quality the higher the better
and so this is the based on solver the
blue one and also is the red one there
are some modifications other
modifications other solvers but again
there is a huge grip
in the basement solver and and pulls
so this algorithm works with purpose
and essentially it was uh so we are
using it for industrial optimization
problems at Intel and in the latest
Market evaluation it was used by the
winner in all the encrypted categories
which was wlsc
okay now
right now I'm done with this time and
you know my own this is my own
approaches to solving this problem
and the point I wanted to make next is
is that I think that so many populates
non-linear optimization problems is an
opportunity for the sub-community
so um it is well known the current is
such best verification comprises
the heaviest uses of starting the
industry right so if you go to for
example to the car 22 program there were
several invited talks
so there wasn't talked by Zach from
Cadence
harvesting the power form of
verification for the Italian dollar chip
designs right so it's about verification
another topic from Amazon the building
smt queries a day which is again about
verification so using Hardware
verification but what about industrial
optimization problems so I think there
should be many of them right in practice
and how could you solve them so you can
do it with with the Imperial linear
programming but then if the problem is
non-linear there are also some
approaches which improve like digital
non-linear programming but
it's not easy to do that because there
might be some Boolean constraints
and also it's not it's really not very
well known how you do it if your
function is a bloodroot function
um so and as I said we already have
something working in the indices so my
intuitive feeling is that um there is a
lot of place of exploration here
um so just let me
talk about cell ideas which I had but
I'm sure there are many more ideas how
you can solve formless optimization
problems with that
so first we used
so we are using sub-based local search
but there is of course classical local
search which you one can also use and
local search is now a component of
modern thoughtfulness and I believe it
can also be harmless forward
solar optimization problems like with
non-linear objective functions
now I can think about dedicated
algorithms for some subclasses
optimization functions
and now the constraints as I presented
in the constraints are just Clauses but
you can think about other types of
questions for example pseudo Boolean
constraints right and then you could
come up with them
simulation algorithm for for other types
of constraints not not only a complex
optimization functions but also more
corporate from things and then
one can look for more applications
so again so I think that I think that if
we have industrial applications at input
that's just because we are looking there
you know if if you look at the broader
industrial problems I'm quite sure if I
can find many optimization problems
which are currently not very well solve
D so that's my message for this part of
the talk and I think that I am done yes
so thank you for your attention
we have plenty of time for questions
I just have clarification questions yes
so when you say
um
we have these constraints about the
placement these are encoded as Sienna
Clauses as well right and so the
question is that
um uh Sienna formula uh how many
satisfying Solutions does it typically
have in an application does it have lots
or couples yes because it normally it
has lots of solutions and
um so you just need to find a good
solution out of medium Solutions which
it has and yeah I think that maybe
you're thinking about symmetry breaking
no no no no no I'm just thinking about
it okay so you have you have this
objective function you know which is the
thing that you want to optimize right
and it depends on these uh Boolean
variables that describe the constraints
yes
um
you know if the problem if the
constraints are infeasible then that
optimization is just meaningless right
so it must have I'm just curious to know
are there many many many solutions that
will give you some value of your
objective function and then you're
looking for the smallest one for example
yes normally there are many many
solutions and you're looking for the
minimals yeah one good solution and also
again you do not really have to encode
your function into clauses I understand
that but I understand that
um so the next question is every time
somebody talks about local search in the
context of vector I can search I get
extremely confused so what exactly is
the local search that's happening over
here is it self solver after it finds a
solution now flipping bits and seeing if
there are in the neighborhood any other
Solutions is that what's happening
you found the solution and you want to
find the solution nearby you want to
make this assume finding a solution yeah
right the one thing you can do
independental process
and say you block the solution then you
want to find a solution nearby you just
modify your product selection heuristic
so as every time variable is picked its
polarity is fixed to the polarity in the
solution and then you're likely to find
the solution in your body and that
seamless local source so that's that's
kind of the core of what I mean
you see so again you you run a subtle or
some problem over the channel formula
you found the solution
independent of optimization now your
phone you want to find a closed solution
a solution nearby
so you block your your previous solution
for example with the close and what what
you do you run your server incrementally
and you modify its polarity selection
heuristic so it picks a variable and
instead of using this phase same
polarity selection or whatever you just
always select the value in the latest
model for every variable and then you
will stay close to the last Model
and that's why I I talk I I refer to it
as local search because you kind of stay
look you stay near okay latest model in
my understanding Google search is you
get a complete assignment and then you
arbitrarily flip a bit and you get a
neighbor yes
you flip a bit differently by by so call
it something else don't call it local
search standard so no
foreign
speed up your soul because you you find
the solution you look around but then
maybe when you find a new solution when
you do this local search if you don't
like the neighborhood but whatever
looking around the neighborhood you you
forgot everything that you yeah it could
be a good idea but I didn't go in any
relationship
I just want to quickly ask the cell
placement problems what sort of the
industrial tasks does that come up in
um
so if you design a chip eventually you
need to place the resistance on the chip
right right so you need to place all you
know winners of transistors and so you
divide these tasks into many sub tasks
placement then is replace cells like in
What's called the farm
and then you place place in places to
place Farms on a partition then
partitions on a chip so there are many
stages of placement but you know we need
to do it somehow
thanks
so actually two comments on two
questions so for the last one from Nina
I think this is happening naturally if
they are using Polo sat in some
algorithms where you are not too much in
as a problem that is defined by the core
that you just got in the solver in the
Microsoft solver
then you are using information
indirectly of the core okay it's not
that you are covering all the subclasses
you're just focusing on NASA problem
you're trying to get the best assignment
there
and actually uh a name for this local
search that was why not to call it
Microsoft space saving right
this is something like
it works not only for Max right yeah but
uh more or less this is what you are
doing this is face Saving right not
really not really because there is this
algorithm which which tries to flip the
bits like a local search right so you go
over all the all the bed of the robots
and you try to flip them so I understood
that you said that you blocked the
solution
for example okay
yeah do is like go over this absorbers
and try to flip them but instead of
working on complete assignments you find
the solution and and then
over skip a bit but
instead of operating complete
assignments you just run a subtle with
deadbeat the negation of the being being
an assumption
and you also use polarity face savings
polarity selection schemes
um yeah and you also need to use for
fixation doesn't work
um so you mentioned about uh non-linear
optimizations for this vectors correct
so um have you thought about like going
into do some
reduction to Nia because recently like
smthenia has improved a lot yeah uh we
we tried doing something with large bit
width like 256 bit why are going to Nia
and it turned out to be better than a
bit blasting so it depends on the
constraint so um you have some
constraints which which can be easily
expressed as like so-called designers so
I haven't talked about it at all but
there are some additional questions
which we are adding to the formula and
in order to use non-linear athletic we
would need to convert them to no linear
constraints and I'm not entire show it's
one can do it efficiently that's you
know one major
yeah so uh we did some
umtinia and uh solving with vectors with
large with like 256 with non-linear
constraints okay so I guess it would be
a nice Direction yeah
[Music]
and maybe a couple of more questions
and hi just an observation and then I I
have a question but I guess they are
separate I don't want to be in the game
of sort of finding a name for this but I
think it could be called local search
because for me the defining feature is
you have a solution then you have a
local neighborhoods yes and then you
evaluate candidate Solutions in the
neighborhoods and through the face
saving and the bit flipping you do have
a neighborhood definition yes right uh
my solution was my question was
different though there's a related
Paradigm I I thought is as you gave as
you entered the talk which is large
neighborhood search is this something
you compare against of those how does
this relates to large neighborhood
search
um maybe it relates to the our follow-up
work in network what we do is we use a
SAT or and Polo such over as an Oracle
and they do a local search on top of it
so and maybe this relate sample to large
neighborhood search because we are using
this solvers again to look for solution
in neighborhoods
so we have this local search inside
this
and then on top of that we are also
trying to find Solutions in
neighborhoods too yeah I didn't talk
about it but maybe we can talk offline
thank you
if it's fitting that the last question
you know talk about conflict driven
close learning start solving is given to
karab again
nice I just you mentioned something
about boosting visits and I didn't quite
understand that so boosting the scores
of these sets you know is hastening
finding conflicts no no no no the idea
is in the form so
you have um
the absorbers and if you why you want to
find a solution which in which The
Observers are zero are minimized right
it's a solution with um as many
falsified absorbers as possible
now there is the polarity selection
realistic which which assign them zero
independent of the variable selection
but then if if you select them first if
visit selects these variables first
there is a better chance to get a
solution which is minimized you see
if for example if you over select them
if you force your variable decision
heuristic to select them first always
then well the soul will get stuck but
you will get the minimum solution
if it doesn't make sense if you always
select them first right because then you
would always select them first and try
to assign them zeros
so you select them from assigned and you
just Define to me what observable means
here in this context
are the variables on which this function
is defined so you want to find a
solution in which
yeah so you want to find the solution in
which The Observers are as close to zero
as possible like
why is it different from this what why
is observables the set of observable is
different and the scope of your
objective function
well it's it's yeah it's the fact the
variable solution function depends so
yeah yeah so variables involved in the
objective function it's not very
variables involving the objective
functions is the variables in which
so
this narrow usage the function
um
is modeled and absorbers so if you flip
and observer from one to zero then the
function gets closer to zero and it
doesn't hold for every variable we shall
you know used by the function oh so the
scope of the objective function can be
bigger than the set of observables yes
so thank you I think let's thank the
speaker again
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're now having had an hour break
and